since we're talking about super bowl i
also want to follow up on our our friend
sal who was hypnotized and thought that
angels were telling him who you know who
to bet oh yeah what were his predictions
his [ __ ] scene angels
well he got uh he bet 500 he was so
convinced that angels were talking to
him through the hypnosis that he uh
and he basically lost every bet i should
just tell you
what were his best sal's predictions uh
bengals first to score he lost that one
coin toss coming up tails he lost that
one point spread over 48 and a half he
lost that one
bengals plus four wins so since he had
the plus four he actually he actually
won that one
uh gatorade being yellow and green he
lost that one saudi you still believe in
uh are your angels
i don't i've been racking my brain for
the past since the game's been over i
don't know what's going on i have to
have a talk with these angels no [ __ ]
the first time
maybe what
you're not talking to angels you were
hypnotized you're talking to yourself
and you know nothing about football so
therefore your angels were wrong
how's that so
yeah i don't know i think but what are
you everything every time your theories
are going to be much more interesting
than our words well everything that i
picked was the opposite so i'm thinking
maybe the alternate universe was sending
me the opposite answers i should have
done that
the universe got involved
and you know what do you mean the
alternate universe yeah the that
universe and i you know the song still
no no what does that mean how can i let
that go by the alternate universe
yeah the alternate there's an i mean
where the angels are they're in an
alternate universe so i'm thinking that
in that alternate universe it doesn't
work like the way we work as human
beings so maybe everything was opposite
like the way the the communication was
the opposite so why wouldn't the angels
tell you to go the opposite of what
they're thinking
because i don't know maybe that's what i
i think if i do it again i will do the
opposite of everything they're telling
me and i think i can win super bowl 2023
that way but you just got one bet right
i got one bet right so maybe they threw
me a bone i don't know i don't know or
my second theory is that howard
great man that he is has stronger angels
than me deservingly so and they were
they wanted howard to look really good
for this segment and me to look like a
total idiot like
wow okay
aren't you glad you asked